l'acqua sarà un giorno un combustibile
l'idrogeno e l'ossigeno di cui è
composta offriranno una sorgente
inesauribile di luce di calore
l'idrogeno sarà il carbone del futuro
Questo è quello che ci diceva Giulio
Verne nel 1874
150 anni fa
Anch'io ho detto con coinvolgimento i
romanzi di verde e la terra de Luna
20.000 leghe sotto i mari Ma L'isola
misteriosa e la prospettiva di una fonte
inesauribile di energia mi ha sempre
entusiasmato
Quanti di voi hanno giocato con una
macchinina radiocomandata prima delle
batterie al litio
qualche minuto di divertimento e poi
nulla
questa delusione assieme alla
prospettiva di una fonte inesauribile di
energia ha fatto sì che fin da bambino
avesse deciso di occuparmi di idrogeno e
di farne il mio lavoro
Ebbene
quella che i tempi di Verne e poi della
mia adolescenza era una visione
fantastica e oggi un progetto condiviso
della scienza delle autorità pubbliche e
dell'Industria
Il problema è che l'idrogeno non è una
fonte di energia l'idrogeno è un vettore
energetico
non è che lo troviamo in una miniera
come il carbone l'idrogeno sulla terra
bisogna generarlo e per generarlo serve
energia
il sistema il processo e verde pulito
solo se questa energia proviene da fonti
rinnovabili come il sole il vento
ma il sole il vento possono veramente
offrirci tutte le energie di cui abbiamo
bisogno per generare l'idrogeno
sì
Come si vede da questa enorme sfera
gialla alle mie spalle
il volume della sfera gialla rappresenta
l'energia che ogni anno la terra riceve
dal sole
mentre la sfera rossa quella più piccola
rappresenta il fabbisogno di energia di
tutte le attività dell'uomo sulla terra
per un anno la sfera verde rappresenta
l'energia che potremmo raccogliere col
vento mentre quelle grigia l'energia
racchiusa in tutti i giacimenti di
carbone sulla terra
Il problema è come trasformare la luce
del sole in energia utile per le nostre
città per le nostre automobili
Oggi possiamo trasformare in modo
efficace l'energia del sole in
elettricità usando i pannelli solari
però non riusciamo ancora a
immagazzinare grandi quantità di energia
nelle batterie
e ancor di più non riusciamo a ridurre
il consumo di combustibili fossili per i
processi industriali per esempio
l'utilizzo del carbone per la produzione
dell'acciaio
utilizzare la luce del sole e ancora una
sfida aperta È importante
fotovoltaici stanno ricoprendo i tetti
delle nostre abitazioni ma ad oggi solo
il 10% dell'energia elettrica nel mondo
e prodotta in questo modo
e poi dobbiamo ricordare
che solo il 20% dell'energia che noi
utilizziamo sulla terra e utilizzata
sotto forma di elettricità
Il rimanente 80 per cento è costituito
dal consumo di una molecola ovvero di un
combustibile principalmente di origine
fossile che utilizziamo per le navi gli
aerei e per produrre l'acciaio
Ebbene
Ci piacerebbe esistesse una molecola
capace di raccogliere la luce del sole e
Sostituire i combustibili fossili
questa molecola esiste Ed è proprio
l'idrogeno l'idrogeno
è un gas e un gas combustibile che ha
tre caratteristiche fondamentali
può essere prodotto in modo pulito
dall'acqua
quando lo si usa non inquina
produce acqua ritorno ad essere acqua e
non produce anidride carbonica
è molto simile al gas naturale e quindi
si potrebbe derivare dall'infrastruttura
utilizzata per il metano
le tubazioni e gli stoccaggi per il suo
utilizzo
oggi l'idrogeno è usato come
combustibile nelle automobili in
alternativa il gas naturale e al GPL ma
soprattutto l'utili idrogeno potrebbe
essere potrebbe esserci utile per i
cosiddetti processi ad alti intensità
energetica dove l'elettricità e le
batterie non possono essere utilizzati
pensate che per attraversare l'Atlantico
come una nave è mossa da batterie ci
servirebbe trainare un'altra nave carica
di batterie
ma soprattutto l'idrogeno può essere
utile per far l'acciaio lavorazione oggi
è responsabile del 10% della produzione
di anidride carbonica mondiale
l'idrogeno oggi può sostituirsi quasi
interamente al carbone e se l'idrogeno
viene prodotto da fonti rinnovabili con
minima produzione di anidride carbonica
Ebbene abbiamo trovato la molecola per
sostituire il combustibili fossili Il
problema è che l'idrogeno verde quello
prodotto da fonti rinnovabili costa
ancora molto e la domanda è bassa
per ridurre il costo abbiamo bisogno di
aumentare contemporaneamente domanda e
offerta
questo può avvenire sviluppando l'intera
filiera idrogeno in area di estensione
limitata
queste aree oggi vengono chiamate
Hydrogen Valley o Valli dell'idrogeno
come dire delle sedi convalide
dell'idrogeno Dove si concentrano
risorse e competenze al fine di portare
sviluppo e benessere nel pieno rispetto
della sostenibilità ambientale
queste aree sono ancora in fase di
sperimentazione l'obiettivo è quello di
realizzare un numero sempre più grande e
poi di collegarle In modo tale da
Estendere la regione nelle quali si
abbandona l'utilizzo di combustibili
fossili a favore delle energie
rinnovabili
energia rinnovabili prodotte localmente
quindi limitando la dipendenza da paesi
lontani con le conseguenti complicazioni
e rischi
bene
qui in Friuli Venezia Giulia quest'anno
è stata costituita la prima Hydrogen
Valley a livello transnazionale in
Europa ai sei mesi territori di Slovenia
e Croazia una zona in cui sviluppare una
forte economia di scala e sfruttare le
risorse della ricca comunità scientifica
dei territori
Ma come funziona un Hydrogen Valley
nell'aldi vengono prodotte grandi
quantità di energia elettrica a partire
dalle fonti rinnovabili come il sole il
vento questa energia
può essere subito utilizzato per
ricaricare le automobili o per le città
ma soprattutto L'energia elettrica può
essere utilizzata negli elettrolitatori
degli impianti che consentono di
trasformare l'acqua H2O in idrogeno H2
Ecco quindi the lightroom le abbiamo
raccolto la luce del sole l'abbiamo
trasformata nella molecola che poi si
trasforma in un combustibile In
alternativa al combustibile fossile per
alimentarla Acciaierie e cementifici
l'idrogeno non immediatamente consumato
può essere immagazzinato per un
successivo utilizzo per esempio quando
la luce del sole non ci sarà o può
essere usato delle navi negli aerei dove
le batterie sarebbe troppo pesanti e
ingombranti
Ledger Valli e quindi un ecosistema nel
quale le attività industriali rimangono
in esercizio ma vengono alimentate da
energia pulita
adesso in Valle è un progetto importante
ma per conseguire l'obiettivo di
neutralità climatica e basso costo di
energia c'è ancora della strada da fare
Dobbiamo investire in ricerca sia per
trovare nuove soluzioni sia per
migliorare le tecnologie esistente
oggi l'idrogeno sta sostituendo il
carbone
e la mia macchinina farebbe molta più
strada ma non tutti potrebbero averla
per averla a tutti dobbiamo impegnarci
ed essere consapevoli che siamo tutti
parte del sistema energetico e possiamo
incidere su di questo a partire dalle
nostre scelte abitudini ed azioni
quotidiane
coniugando questo impegno e le ricerche
scientifiche da Sanremo in eredità alle
nuove generazioni un mondo con la
qualità della vita migliore è ricco di
opportunità
garantendone allo stesso tempo
la sostenibilità Grazie
[Applauso]